[Applause]
final seconds
brian for the win
so
james catches puts up the three
one go rebound box
[Applause]
with five seconds remaining
spurs do not have a timeout
but the officials are going to review to
see if allen was behind the line
[Music]
chris bosh with the huge offensive
rebound
and now instant replay enormous
and mike
tim duncan
out of the game
leads to the second shot and clearly a
three-point shot
they confirmed that it was a three
and the spurs had a chance to talk this
over
rose misses another
smith has it nick's down three should
the bulls foul no
anthony for three
bang
that one goes down and the game is tied
separate on the drive out to anthony
smith the three-pointer way off the mark
chandler tips it out again
and the knicks will reset down by two
mike whitson not calling timeout
and i like that move
in the hands of anthony
anthony for three
puts it in next by one with 8.2
remaining
and again you've got a six nine guy on
you
he's a couple of feet again beyond the
arc
for both teams hitting such big shots
shepard picks him up on the switch they
both fall down inside to noah
noah on the dribble back out to corvor
final seconds rose dribbles it off rose
drives puts it up no good and the next
win in overtime
what a thriller at madison square garden
carmelo anthony perhaps his finest
moment as a nick
two clutch threes one at the end of
regulation
one on the final seconds of overtime
looking
finds rose
rose trying to get open fires away
it's over the bulls win at the buzzer
and i just gotta thank my teammates man
they give me so much energy they give me
so much um confidence man to give me the
ball when i need it and they live with
me they live with my mistakes
unfortunately they're very fortunate
coming up on a minute remaining
[Applause]
brian
our test that's the three
[Applause]
they do have a timeout decide not to use
it curry way
downtown bang oh what a shot from curry
with six tenths of a second remaining
the brilliant shooting of stephen curry
continues
and he ties the nba record with his 12th
three-pointer of the game
[Applause]
[Music]
westbrook gets off a decent look the
banker
and you've got to press up
[Applause]
roberson just a little late but that's
just
man that's about 35 feet out well beyond
the 28 foot mark
set up
the crowd on its feet here at the air
canada center
knicks take the lead
amazing here at the air canada center
five tenths of a second remaining
when sanity continues
and the raptors can't believe their luck
they had the lakers down
kobe
with the dagger
and now lynn
pulverizing them straight on with the
hoop
jeremy lin with a clutch three-pointer
he now has 27.